could you look at all the mathematical  structures that are known to exist and  say there must be some physical  instantiation of that and you've called  it a grand unified theory could you  discover new physics that we don't know  about now I would say this is one of  those cases where I would say I don't  know may well be true maybe not it's  possible that mathematics is not  necessarily focused on the or pain to do  the physical reality because it is a  kind of activity of the mind right so in  a way one could also say that it's like  a Venn diagram where you have an overlap  between the two but little subjects are  developed on separate